do you have a routine when you're
starting a screenplay whether it's a
feature-length is short I often write
backwards I often think of an ending and
then I think what's a fun way to get
there so I often do that and then I
think about it I think about it a lot I
just didn't let it just let it boil
around in there for a while and then and
then I outline it right you know
outlining getting the story right that's
the hardest part once you've got all
that down which I got the story working
in the characters working then it's just
easy to to write it up half the stuff
I've sold everything with partners
because you know comedy is great to work
with a partner because you know you can
you can work off of each other
you'll make a suggestion they'll make a
suggestion and you play off each other's
pitches and then you arrive at something
hopefully that neither of you would have
gotten to a loan that's better so when
you working with a in comedy with a
writing partner it speeds it up here
like a drafter too ahead of what you
would have been if you've been doing it
alone what are your best screenwriting
habits and then what are your worst
screen already habits and you don't have
to give me five I don't know you just
hurt my best screenwriting habits you
know I hate to say this but there's no
there's no like magic habit or thing you
just put your butt in the chair and you
just write it's a job so whether you
feel like it or not you sit and you do
your job I mean there's no magic I've
had some young writers say to me oh I'm
going on this writing retreat for a
weekend so I can finally work on my
script and like what I've never been on
a retreat to write I will just just
write there's nothing magical about it
sure maybe the first draft will be you
know poopoo but if you don't write the
first draft you won't write the second
draft it's it just have to demystify
times people just build it up and do
this a big magical thing demystification
just
just do it my works have in my own
writing the last thing I put in is
visual comedy and set-pieces because
that's not where my mind goes first I
have to remind myself make this visual
you know some of the physical a big set
piece where crazy big stuff happens and
that's just something that it's the last
thing I do because I don't think about
it first so that's that's all I just I
per my myself oh we could do something
big here and then I and then I put it in
and is that your worst screenwriting how
much are bad I mean that's your worst
okay just like that's that's like that's
like a weakness it's a weakness that I
that I don't that it's not like there
from the start I have to say you know
it's like when you leave the house and
you go oh did I leave the stove on I'm
gonna have to be like oh did I put in oh
no okay that's all I mean there's
nothing mysterious about it you just
just write just write your script I mean
you can't you can't teach writing you're
either a writer or you're not you can
teach technique you can teach craft you
can teach how to fix certain problems
but if you're a writer you're writing
every day and if you have time they're
right there today you're you're thinking
about it for the new writers though
don't you think they almost need a
ritual I know I know this retreat idea
for someone who has written it sounds
like why would you need all that why
would you need to fly there and pay
money whatever but maybe some people
need that ritual no just just you know
OMA in churches they had rituals
Christmastime is a ritual no the only
ritual is sit down and write it's that's
the only ritual there's there's nothing
else to it I it really isn't I mean I
wish there was some kind of magical and
people also ask me gee what book should
I read on screenwriting I'm just
starting write wide weird I'm like don't
read a book no no don't read a book
write five or six scripts then read a
book because we read a book now it's
abstract it's theoretical you haven't
done it okay that's like saying you know
what sheet music should I buy
do you have an instrument No
pick up an instrument start playing it
first okay because the books will make
no sense I've read like five or six old
scripts before I ever read any books on
screenwriting and then I got a story by
Robert McKee and I'm like oh that's
interesting because I had a problem in a
script I couldn't figure out to solve it
and I was reading that and I go oh
that's I could fix it now if I'd read
that before I had the problem then that
particular chapter would have made no
sense to me
because I didn't have that problem yet
because I hadn't written enough I mean I
always say these new writers and like I
say when they talk to me about getting
books and doing these things like that I
say how many scripts have you written
and if they answer me with a number if
they know how many scripts I've written
how many scripts they've written they
haven't written enough scripts you
should know how many scripts you've
written you should be ready so any
scripts that you'd have to think about
it for a minute and figure out oh I
wrote this and then if you know like how
many drafts exactly you did or something
you haven't done enough drafts I mean
once you do so much of this you build
the muscles you just keep writing
writing right away you build up the
writing muscles and then you don't need
rituals you don't need this stuff
because you know you built it up you can
do it you said earlier about writers
under 30 that they really hadn't lived
life and I'm sure it would depend on the
individual yes I mean you know there
could be some people that have lived by
the time they're 15 and others by the
time they're 50 you know everything's
been safe and easy and taken care of for
them but what are some things where they
could live life let's suppose they have
just a normal life with some good some
bad ups and downs how can they how can
they live life to sort of you know get a
sort of a right early brain
really bad we're getting toward the end
here I mean you know so they can kind of
have it be a little more well-rounded by
30 or whatever age doesn't matter what
age I guess you just have to be around
people you have to have friends and you
know romances and things like that and
you get your heart broken and break some
hearts and you know just you know don't
don't sit at home watching you know
don't go to work for your day job come
on and watch TV for six hours and go to
bed go go to meetups go do stuff be with
people because that's what matters I
thought I was some weirdo who liked
doing this by found out that other
people other writers like to do this
which is if you're in a cafe or whatever
eavesdrop other people around you
because you are you're hearing real
dialogue and real stuff and it's really
illuminating you know so I don't know
it's the only advice I can offer is to
just get the heck out of you're out of
your apartment
get off your futon go live life
you